so welcome thank you for coming i only
have seven hours of remarks so i thought
i ought to start a little early we are
going to begin now i hope is people come
in they'll feel comfortable grabbing
food and you won't mind going back to
get seconds we will keep covenant and
end it two o'clock but we're going to
organize this a little differently
yesterday because the question of a
mission trip is so context dependent and
you're going to have a lot of things
that you do at your church that are
different than what we do at our church
you're going to be doing things at our
church that don't translate even as idea
generators so we're going to organize it
a little bit more as a workshop so that
i'll present some idea generators and
then leave you 10 or 15 minutes to talk
at table so that you can swap ideas then
we'll come back all right let me say
table grace gracious God for the new
beginnings that constantly come from
your hand for the new beginnings of a
new year for the opportunity to gather
and break bread together and fellowship
together we thank you for all these we
pray that in our in our time together
old friendships will be renewed and new
friendship started we pray that you'll
bless to us a sense of your spirit
guiding us as we seek and ask how to
minister to your children we ask for all
this as we ask for a blessing on this
food and the hands that prepared it in
Jesus name Amen alright here's how we're
going to start we're going to just start
with a little a little last clip from
our mission trip at our church last year
to Biloxi Mississippi we had gone on a
mission trip there right after Hurricane
Katrina you all know that they're not
beginning to be done with rebuilding in
places like East Biloxi so we went back
last year and we partnered with 25 local
churches and nine churches hosted our
teams that resulted in a final
celebration and worship and you're just
going to see a bit of that with voice
overs from our kids and if you pay
attention to these five minutes you
don't need to listen for the rest of the
day because our kids will teach you
better than I can teach you all right
here it is
you
I've got a better way to use our time
than that as moving and evocative visit
okay here's what I'll do while we're
getting organized this is what happens
when a 62 year old tries to have
technology in the middle of a talk I
have some thank yous the binders that
you've got before you the dvds that have
all the documents in the binder in
digital form and then more these have
been put together by some really hard
working people Kim who is back there Kim
case was a senior in our youth group
five years ago and is back helping out
Kelly Morrissey and Lee angin all had a
hand in that at your tables many of you
have folks who have worked with our
youth group or currently youth ministry
initiative fellows when you folks raise
your hands if you're at a table
somewhere it's not so that they can tell
you more about our program tell so you
should be sitting somewhere else y
double up over there Chris know when we
have our breakouts if you have questions
they'll just try to keep the
conversation going and I want to thank
Joe Britain for the opportunity to have
this program he helped us get a foothold
on the Yale campus when we taught at the
Berkeley divinity school last year and I
get to do this because Miroslav Volf
welcomed us into the yale center for
faith and culture so miroslav thank you
sir thank you sir all right I'm going to
start with we're going to we're going to
race through this outline in sections
and here's the question i'm at a i'm at
a habitat site on a work day for
something we sponsored in Bridgeport and
one of my shrewd business colleague
types who works downtown was working
with me he said you know I would feel
more comfortable about making donations
to your youth group if you were more
efficient in the way you got the work
done I mean I don't understand why we're
spending all this money on
transportation and food and housing why
don't you just put the kids on a bus in
the morning and bring them up to
Bridgeport all that money could go into
houses what's the right answer to that
question
why bring him up in buses at all why
don't we just cut a check right if the
efficiency question is how do we
generate the most construction for folks
who need it in a world that has
marginalized them or left them without
housing we should simply raise money and
send a check to qualified professional
contractors who need the work in the
community they will get more done than
we get done by going on a mission trip
right the dirty little secret of mission
trips I don't put this at the top of my
fundraising letters is there will never
ever be a mission trip where as much
work would be done as we could have
accomplished if we just sent them a
check for the airfare the housing the
train the vans or whatever we don't go
on mission trips just or maybe even
principally to build houses we would
send checks if that's what we were
principally about which raises the
question why do we go on mission trips
why do we take people on mission trips
now I didn't think about that when I ran
my first mission trip I was a student
intern here in gilf and at Yale and I
was working out of the First
Congregational Church in Guilford they
did mission chefs let's do mission chefs
okay you do mission trips and I just
kind of went with the program but if you
think about it for even just a couple of
moments I think you'll realize that well
if we're going to go to this work we
ought to do theological reflection
before we go as to what our purpose is
you all know the cliche but I think it's
worth reading out from Alice in
Wonderland Alice says mr. cat which of
these paths shall I take cheshire cat
well my dear where do you want to go
Alice I don't suppose it really matters
cheshire cat then my dear any path will
do I promised you a nuts-and-bolts talk
but nuts and bolts are going to be
entirely different depending on why
you're going on your mission trip we
ought to be doing some reflection why we
go because the Y will drive the how
right the Y will drive the how more
importantly than that when you think
about it your mission trips sits in the
middle over at the end of your youth
ministry year actually I
think before you reflect on why you do a
mission trip you should reflect on why
you do you three because this is one of
the most powerful experiences you're
going to have embedded in your youth
ministry so I think the reflection backs
up why do we do youth ministry what is
our mission in doing youth ministry that
will inform why we do mission trips and
that will inform how we do mission trips
are we ready we're going to try this
film again again this will this will
cover everything i'm going to say for
the next hour
one thing we talked about la the mission
trip was agape which is unconditional
love and basically everyone on the trip
even if you don't know them you're going
to love them unconditionally you're
going to accept them for who they are
and you actually get to know people
really well on the trip
it's yg tradition to end the mission
trip with a final celebration we do this
to express gratitude to God in the
Biloxi community it's also a time to
celebrate play sing and worship
alongside new friends and to reflect on
the most amazing moments of mature
you
when you get to the end of the work week
you get to look back on all the things
that you've done and that's pretty good
but you realize that the best part about
your week has been connecting with the
people and helping in any little way you
can I think that's what hope CDA is
really all about neighbors helping
neighbors and people coming together
that is what a mission trip is really
all about
I think the most powerful moment I
experienced God's present on the trip
was the final celebration when we were
all sitting in a circle and we were
singing Amazing Grace and everyone just
kind of closed their eyes held hands and
we all just became one community only
like God could bring us together like
that
I think the service we did biloxi is
important because we're not only helping
to rebuild homes but we're helping
rebuild the community there it's really
hard for a community to hold together
all its bonds just by helping to make
the community stronger so vital
I don't think my sense of spirituality
necessarily changed on the trip I think
it became stronger because it's such a
community and there's so much time to
recognize God's grace it definitely like
increases your sense of spirituality and
felt like God is always there for you
especially in our church when the whole
group is together
the most valuable thing to me was
learning that unconditional love does
exist we spoke about that so much on the
trip but it just hit home so hard for me
and I just felt it all the time I felt
it during the worship service I thought
it was my team every single day and it
just blew my mind it makes you feel so
light and full at the same time and I
was just so happy because I don't think
I've ever felt pure unconditional love
before this trip
alright so if what we're searching
seeking is why do we do youth when so we
know why we do mission trips so we know
how we do mission trips I have an
acknowledgement a challenge and an
introduction here's the acknowledgement
there is no one universally accepted
theology of why we do youth when istry
depending on our traditions our churches
our histories they're all over the lot
I've given you seven or eight different
articulations but you can well imagine
how the articulation is going to drive
the reason to do youth ministry trips
which is going to drive how you do the
trips that's the that's the
acknowledgement here's the challenge I
want to I want to just provocatively
poke at a couple of ways that I've seen
we end up often doing mission trips that
are not necessarily driven by our
theology and our mission of youth
ministry one of them is the add on
mission trip the add-on mission trip is
a church comes to me and says we're
really looking to build our youth
ministry we'd love to learn from you I
say well how are you doing how's your
youth ministry going they say well we
get about five kids a week but we get 60
kids on the mission trip I said well do
you ask the kids on the mission trip to
come to the youth group as part of the
condition of going on the trip oh no we
they wouldn't do that and what would you
say to the parents they've got so much
to do with soccer games and s80 prep
courses and tutoring they have
essentially made the mission trip and
add on to their youth group year and
therefore they have stripped out the
integration the theology the practices
the relationship building of the year
and no it's not true that they won't
come we have incremental e increased the
Covenant elec SPECT Asians of our kids
and we've gone from 17 kids on the
mission trip to 150 a year they will
come in fact the more depth that you add
to the program the more meaning that you
add to the program the more the
relationships deepened the more they
will make the time to come so that's the
add-on mission trip this apart from our
separate mission trip often it's what we
can do we don't have the staff to run a
mission trip we don't have the resources
to run a mission trip and we send the
kids to a mission trip
facilitator okay if that's driven by
necessity I get it but if you have the
resources to make an integral part of
your youth ministry year I think you're
selling off your birthright for a mess
of porridge or here's a third one it's
the the third one is the instead of
youth ministry we've got a terrific
youth group and we've got we got 75 kids
to go on mission trips but we realized
that if we didn't impose Christian
doctrine and practices even more kids
would feel comfortable and therefore
we've gotten our mission trip up to 125
kids who were doing service learning and
relationship building that's terrific
and then actually we found they were
uncomfortable coming during the year
when we had Christian content so we
dropped the Christian content during the
year and we have made the year mission
trip preparation for the mission team
once again I get it but I think we're
selling our birthright and stripping out
our youth ministry of one of the most
important drivers of youth ministry and
formation for our group okay that's the
that's the challenge here's the
introduction obviously our nuts and
bolts our house are going to be driven
by why we do mission trips which is
driven by our theology of youth ministry
and we are time sensitive so I I work
that out in a lecture to the Berkeley
Divinity School colloquium last year
it's in your first tab you can get the
long form there I've embedded a bunch of
quotations so that you can see how we
got there here but because Mears laughs
here I just want to tell three quick
yale vignettes because some of you have
been in this room before and so we'll
just call down the spirit of Yale
Divinity School for a second here's
here's what I remember from leander kick
this used to be the common room right we
would gather in here before we'd go to
the refectory land erkek amazing
theologian dean of the Yale Divinity
School Dean of the Vanderbilt Divinity
School professor of New Testament was
teaching the gospel of john one day and
he said look I think I can summarize the
gospel and the three letters this is the
way the theologian who was the
evangelist evolved over the course of
his career with his community when he
began his theology was blah blah blah
blah love
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah love by the time he got to his
first letter he had aged and had some
more experience in ministry by the time
of his first letter the theology of the
Evangelist was blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah love and by the time he
got to his third letter at the end of
his career was love love love love love
all right a Miroslav Volf in yet one of
the great things about having a speaker
come and join you for a series as you
get to give them homework and so
miroslav was coming down to try out some
lectures that would become his book free
of charge and that means I'm going to
take him out to dinner that means what's
the quick what's the one question you
want to ask the greatest theologian in
the world if you gotten stuck at dinner
so I thought about that a lot on I've
got him stuck at dinner and there's
really no way he can escape and i said
you know i have read paul tillich say
that the experience of grace is
intermittent and fragmentary our
encounters with a spiritual reality
intermittent and fragmentary you know
that seems like kind of small small
gruel I mean is I know that grace means
there's nothing we can do it's unmerited
but is there anything we can do to make
the ground better soil and he said I
suppose the theological germanica has
something to say about that well
theologian icky is what trips off his
lips but what I'm going is what did he
just say what is the theologian
mannequin so I acted you know I didn't
wanted to realize how poorly educated
I'd been at Yale so I didn't say
anything but soon as I got back to my
office I googled it of course and up
came a book that was Martin Luther's
favorite devotional work and his
favorite book other than the Bible and
agustin an anonymous 13th century German
authors devotional writing and here's
the gist of the book on the first page
the author says when we ask why we do
not experience God it makes no more
sense than why the blind man should ask
what he does not see the Sun the Sun is
always present its his blindness that
obscures the site what is it about us
that is blind and obscures the site an
incredibly modern kind of
him the me the mine and the my the turn
to self is what obscures the experience
of God and much of our devotional
practices theology is to turn from self
back to God a neighbor well these ideas
had much to do with informing our sense
of mission and so the other thing I'd
think I'd want to say do you remember
when Andy route with with us Andy route
last year spoke on relationship and he
said here's where the love and the
relationship needs to be reflected upon
we should not be loving kids so that
they learned the Bible we should not be
loving kids so they become disciples of
Christ we should not be loving kids so
they don't do drugs all these are good
things that's not what Jesus would do he
would just love them that's what we
should be doing when you should be just
loving them where they are authentic not
instrumental relationship let me give
this a slight twist in the other way you
know when the scribe encounters Jesus
it's chapter 22 of Matthew teacher what
is the greatest commandment we all know
what the answer is right love the Lord
they got all the hearts on my neighbor's
I self what if they'd been a follow-on
question what if the follow-on question
was teacher what is the greatest
commandment for youth ministry what do
you think Jesus would have said turn
them into Church attenders I don't think
so I think it would have been love the
Lord thy God with all thy heart they saw
their mind and thy neighbor as thyself
so if you turn to page six you'll have
one story that captures out of one of
our kids mouths why we do mission trips
and why we do you three the child says I
get an email from the mom says my two
boys my twins were home right after the
mission trip and I just couldn't
understand why they were so lit up and
what happened and they struggled to
explain to me what it was and they said
mom for ten days we loved
unconditionally supported one another
there was no judgment there was no
criticism there was nothing but loving
each other and we knew that love came
from God and we went back to school
today and it was so hard back at school
I had a teacher we had a teacher in math
who was just beating on us and
criticizing us and Ben
telling us so my brother and I went up
to her after class and we said it
doesn't have to be like this we have
seen and we have lived another way to
live we just spent ten days working in
the rain nobody judged nobody criticized
only love we knew the love came from God
we got every single thing done that was
you don't have to teach like this we
don't have to be like this and the
teacher looked up and said I understand
what you're saying and she smiled and
then she started to cry and that she
said I'll do it differently tomorrow
that's why we do mission trips so you
can see our mission statement which is
principally we will foster a community
in which our youth may experience and
share the love of God and then a
community in which that is characterized
by unconditional love and acceptance by
clear and understandable boundaries and
covenants and by participation in
something larger than yourself that's
what drives our how now of course you
don't have to reflect on it for a second
to know that's not actually their
culture at the high school so we are
talking about what Paul was talking
about be not conformed to the world but
be transformed by the renewing of your
minds youth ministry is about nurturing
that community so that there may be a
presence of the Living Christ spirit
that is transformative in their walk and
that that gets into well where does
transformation come from and one of my
more amazing buddies here at the
Divinity School in 1993 had this resume
think of you know anybody with this
resume grew up in a martial arts family
enlisted in the Green Beret fought in
Vietnam decided that it turned out the
Green Beret was not the most demanding
and the toughest it was the Navy SEALs
finished his tour went back to San Diego
became a Navy SEAL fought in Vietnam
then fought in Afghanistan with the
Mujahideen on the side of the Shiites
came out of Afghanistan and had a
conversion experience and went to
harvard divinity school to learn
theology
came here to become an Episcopal priest
I said this guy knows something about
transformation so I I said Shannon
sometimes we preach and we preach and we
teach and we teach and we're not sure
there is transformation what do you
learn I think I missed the three years
he spent in the Shaolin Buddhist
monastery in China he said he said
actually we know exactly how
transformation works we know it in a
green beret boot camp we know it in SEAL
training we know it at law schools at
medical schools everywhere we really
care about transformation we know how to
do it you take the person out of their
comfort zone away from their home into
the counterculture strictly reinforcing
the mutual values of that culture give
them a different look at different life
that is destabilizing what eventually
becomes transformative and then they go
home with the transformation in place
we've seen this before right the Navy
SEALs did not invent this this is what
pilgrimages have been for thousands of
years this is what the pilgrims do on
the Campostella pilgrimage is what the
pilgrims do on the Lord's pilgrimage
this is what the pilgrims did in the
Middle Ages when they went to Rome or
Jerusalem or wherever how far back does
this notion of pilgrimage go in our
tradition Jesus is obviously a pilgrim
interest Jerusalem is a pilgrimage the
Eucharist is a pilgrims meal Moses is a
pilgrim people of Israel or pilgrims
Abraham's a pilgrim transformation has
always come to people in motion so we
have this lovely quotation from a tree
ginebra who also haunted this room at
one time pilgrims our purses in persons
in motion passing through territories
not their own seeking something we might
call completion or perhaps the word
clarity will do as well a goal to which
only the spirits compass points the way
and then I've got two great books for if
you want to dig down into the notion of
mission trip as pilgrimage the first is
Trevor Hudson a mile in my shoes
cultivating compassion and the other is
Don Richter mission trips that
header embodied faith for the sake of
the world great line from Trevor Hudson
which we teach all our kids and it's the
touchstone at the beginning of our
mission trips we would come as pilgrims
not tourists as learners not as teachers
as receivers not as givers as listeners
not as talkers all right we need to get
over the notion that a mission trip is
about incredibly well resourced talented
sophisticated first-world people going
to save enlighten and change and enrich
second world or third world people we go
because they have much to teach us much
to give us much that God will give us
both in the encounter all right that's
what drives our mission trips all right
we're going to take a break it's time
for a little workshop experience hold
that a little workshop experience will
give you five ten minutes what drives
youth ministry at your church and how
does your theology of youth ministry
drive your theology of mission trips and
then how does that get instantiated
where you are enjoy we will do another
breakout I I'm sorry that we're so
pinched for time all right I'm going to
quickly cover the topic on page 13 once
you have a theology of youth ministry
which drives the reason you do a mission
trip you're going to want to integrate
the two one less serious one more
serious comment the less serious comment
anybody here old enough to have had
Mattel Hot Wheels all right but the
coolest part of the Mattel hot wheels
which is a little car that low friction
flew around a track had a loop-de-loop
but for that car to make the loop de
loop it had to go through the
supercharger all right or the turbo
booster all right a mission trip is a
supercharger or turbo booster to your
youth group year all right your youth
group year lays down foundations of
practices and relationships and shared
songs and stories that then make your
mission trips so much richer and your
mission trip is you
our youth ministry distillate or
concentrate that gives you the time and
attention and the attention units to
ground and deep in all of those things
remember when Roger nishioka came he
said for true relational authenticity to
established you need 17 contiguous hours
with the same human beings whoa 10 days
24 7 that's turbocharged that's super
booster all right so the two should be
integrated you can see here how we
integrate our mission trip into our
youth group you're intentionally
building in laying down foundations I
think maybe the most important of them
aside from relationship or the practices
the practices the first mission trip I
took I can still remember we got to West
Virginia and I took them into the local
church boy do these kids hate being in
that local church they stood there
awkwardly they kind of didn't know the
songs they look down and they mumble the
songs etc well you can't expect it to be
different on the mission trip if you
haven't been in regular worship during
the year regular prayer regular worship
regular devotionals during the year
create the appetite the custom the
expectation to do it on the mission trip
itself so we have regular worship in our
youth group we have regular singing of
the songs their own hems etc regular
praying for one another that grounds the
experience of the mission trip and then
the mission trip turbocharges it when it
comes home the other way of saying that
is what you do in practice you do in the
game alright what you do in practice you
do in the game no practice no game if
you want coven ental behavior on the
mission trip where everybody pitches in
don't want to go home every night with
the place of mess while you clean up the
hall they need that covenant Oh Behavior
all year long if you expect to get it on
the mission trip all right now you're
saying I drove a long way here and I
paid so much money as a ticket to this
room and lunch was very expensive how am
I going to redeem this expense I'm going
to redeem it for you right now all right
we're a demon I think the most powerful
driver of our youth ministry we fell
into quite accidentally senior
leadership all right ten minutes senior
leadership
we have a commissioning of the seniors
on the mission trip a laying on of hands
and prayers and reflections by the
younger kids this is a child reflecting
the next day on what she said to the
seniors the night before so happy for
the seniors and the first thing that
came to my mind when I thought of them
that was no matter what I do whenever
I'm walking through the hallway at the
high school and I look up and I see a YG
senior I know that they have the biggest
heart that any person could ever have
they're so loving and caring and that
whether I know them or not personally
that they'll always be wonderful to me
all right senior leadership my first
mission trip in 1995 I had the immense
misfortune of following this guy who was
a younger man back in nineteen ninety
one who had who had who was that so as I
who had been the youth minister before
me but he left and we got a Yale intern
who came in so when I came in I was the
third youth minister that that youth
group had had in three years all but two
of my seniors dropped out why should
they stay develop a relationship with
yet another guy I've already been on
three mission trips and oh by the way i
think i got my mom conned and to me and
my girlfriend's going to Cancun on a
senior trip no mission trip for us one
of only two seniors who stuck with me
was Lee angin who is our director of
youth ministry and outreach etc we go
off on the mission trip no senior
leadership no exemplars of what the
behavior should be of course I got the
results of that chase the kids down all
night to try to get him to go to bed
find a kid in a car coming back at
eleven-forty-five at night with one of
the young cool contractors of the
mission center where they've been out
smoking dope and we find three juniors
in a freshman girls room right cops and
robbers all week long cops and robbers
all week one which is the culture at the
high school band trip cops and robbers
sports trips cops and robbers and that's
what's going to be your youth ministry
trip if we don't change the culture
right second year we've got seniors and
they're beating on me we want to stay up
we want to stay up we want to stay ever
you want to stay up and I'm going
and we got to be rested tomorrow we got
to say I forgot to say ever gets it I
can't stay up with you I'm an old man
i'm too tired it's eleven o'clock i need
to go to bed and kate hide and thievery
no said you go to bed you tell us what
time you want him in bed we'll put him
down i said i can't get him down they
run me ragged with cops and robbers they
trust us give us one night what time you
want to go to bed I said what time do
you want to go to bed they go twelve
o'clock they've done I go to bed at
eleven o'clock going man this might be
my last night a youth ministry right
it's got a I'm gonna wake up tomorrow
like Gulliver right tie down you think
those kids went to bed at twelve o'clock
all a senior has to say to a kid who was
acting up as go dude that ain't cool
done it's done it's over you do not mess
with seniors now I would have been glad
to have any leadership cadre and maybe
your culture is different I had a
phenomenal leader who was a junior I
said you should be leading the scripts
because I that's not our school no one
will accept my leadership it has to be a
senior okay senior leadership next year
I started cultivating the for seniors to
be senior leaders they said nobody
respects us they won't listen to us they
don't really look up to us I don't think
this is going to work i said just try it
you will be amazed that if you pour
yourself out philippians 2 5 through 11
canossa sem pour yourself at for these
kids the amount of love that's going to
come washing back is going to amaze you
they did it they were awkward they were
insecure they didn't think they were
making a difference we got to the final
reflection the candles passing and
Kendall Evans says I just want to say
something to the seniors you have loved
us you have cared for us you have taught
us we love you so much we're going to
miss you so much next year we will never
forget you for seniors in the middle of
a circle crying their eyes out 20 kids
around them giving them a group hug
every senior there said I'm doing this
again and every kid who was there said
when I be a senior I gonna do that right
so we have intentionally nurtured that
senior leadership program and you can
see all built around the ethos of
flipping to five through 11 the basic
bottom line is this you are charismatic
you
were wonderful you were theological ed
pure transformative leader and because
you're all those things you will be able
to lift your youth group to a seven on a
scale of ten just by brute leadership
charisma you can't get past that unless
the kids on their own group nobody gets
to attend without the youth group owning
its own leadership all right so you can
see the little checklist I'm going to
just race through them in August we have
a senior retreat we take the seniors on
a three-day whitewater camping etc the
job of the retreat is discern how you
are called by God to put your stamp on
this year what does this year mean for
you when you are senior leaders they
have their own Facebook page they have
seen your meetings on the mission trip
to govern the trip they prepare for the
year's first youth group meeting and
then we come to appoint the meeting we
pull all the advisors out happens to be
at a beach all the advisors walk away
the seniors are taking you down the
beach and they're going to tell you
where they're taking you this year well
you know this senior leadership program
with this kind of ownership has grown
from those four we have 52 senior
leaders this year that's 16 the high
school as a senior and when you are a
freshman and you see that there are 52
Savior's are going to know who you are I
was walking behind two freshmen kids on
a retreat one time and I heard them say
to the other when we get back from this
retreat seniors are going to know our
names all right seniors take care of the
younger kids and we flipped the status
system right which is essential to
pilgrimages this liminal subversion of
the usual status that goes on on
pilgrimage seniors eat last seniors
shower last seniors do never don't ever
sit gunshot seniors don't run the music
seniors or service and that's what keeps
them because the talk to the seniors is
you know what just your fourth mission
trip why go another year why go hanging
around with 14 year olds you know what
the age difference between a 14 year old
boy and a 17 year old girl is 37 years
alright there's no draw in one more turn
of the wheel but you say this is going
to be the most amazing year for you ever
you're going to live this Philippians 2
5 through 11 and you're going to see
that the you that takes you down and
service is going to result in more
amazing experiences of God and love than
you've ever had you are being handed by
God kind of a magic wand your attention
in the hallways at school your favor
your interest your engaging and
investing in a freshman likes them up as
if it were just a blessing that came out
of the sky don't be stingy with your
magic wand here's what I want you to do
before we make a final decision about
whether you want to be a senior leader
and they're sitting in a circle who
changed your life when you were a
freshman and they were senior and they
go Caroline Ainsworth someday someone's
going to say your name in this circle 10
20 30 40 50 it is the best year you can
possibly imagine you live out
Philippines to 5 through 11 we have the
congregation Commission the senior
leaders senior leaders or leaders of
each of the teams senior leadership
dinners meet with the team advisors to
work out the plans for the team's
seniors lead team breakouts they lead
worship they lead Vespers we never shot
up the kids to be quiet Caroline will
say seniors and the seniors go Shh
you're standing next to a senior and
your freshman you're going to be quiet
we don't have to shout at them because
the seniors have their respect seniors
have they try to generate a budget where
we can take a senior on a site visit to
the mission site so the senior engages
the site and advises us on what they
want to do and then comes back and
lights up the rest of the youth group
and is in relationship with the roof the
youth group that we're going to engage
with and you can see the rest of it
where it's migrated is we saw so much
power in senior leadership that we
started taking juniors we will let them
apply and write essays and if they are
accepted they may lead our middle school
youth group who's going to do that who
has time we now have too many to use so
we have distributed them as well into
the junior youth group and the guppies
and the
youth worship so by time they become a
senior they've had four years of
leadership of the younger kids they have
amazing leadership skills all right
that's senior leadership will take a
short break out we'll come back I think
you could have said could you have just
sent me an email so I didn't have to
come I had allowed us to do if the email
just said whatever youth minister knows
relationship relationship relationship
we would have gotten it but the point of
the next little segment is the real
power this is not just relationship
amongst the kids it's true relationship
with the community we're joining with us
partners true relationship with the
church we're going to true relationship
with their youth group true relationship
with the entire community that's when
this gets truly truly beautiful so how
we find such communities and how we
develop those relationships is what
we're going to talk about next we've got
a little video where this has been just
blessed we had a mission trip to Latino
church centro cristiano the bethesda in
the fullerton cicero neighborhood of
chicago amazing relationship broke out
with them they came and visited our
church we've now been on seven mission
trips with them to their sister churches
in Guatemala and Puerto Rico they have
this amazing ability to express
gratitude and engage us in ways that are
you know how loving you try to be they
top you so at the end of the last
mission trip we do a worship service we
thank them as profoundly as we can and
then they had all learned to thank you
song the three year olds to the 80 year
olds they went up and they were singing
it and while they were singing it to us
we had the spiritual insight of Kim case
this young woman who just said we should
not be sitting in pews we should come
forward and there was two communities 80
each falling into a massive group hug we
call it the miracle Milagro continuum
all right little video from that trip
let's go
there is such a sense of unity it didn't
matter who is standing next to you we
were singing we were hugging we were
dancing and nothing else seemed to
matter but what was going on in the
church that day I've had the opportunity
to participate in a lot of final
worships but I've never been in the
presence of such amazing power and
energy kneeling together we sang from
our hearts truly we had become one
when the YG community came together with
the bethesda community during the final
worship it was the most spectacular part
of the trip it literally moved me to
tears standing in that room you felt an
energy
the energy was luck and it was God's
love pouring out of all of us listening
to them seeing their thank you to us and
then joining them up at the front it was
so special we had really become one
community
we went to Chicago for 10 days none of
us having any real expectations of what
we would encounter the only thing that
we really knew at the end of the trip we
had just experienced something amazing
well we all know what the problem with
that is this is a gift of God er it's
not right this is the Holy Spirit starts
whipping around and everybody knows it
and everybody is transformed by it is
there anything we can do to nurture
create the possibility I think we're
back to theologian Annika it's or mears
laughs channels of human love with
Luther or Leander Keck love love love we
have to seek we're relationship true
relationship is possible and here's a
sin of mission trippers you can't impose
that on some community and say we're
coming we're going to be in relationship
guess what it's a burden to have 20 kids
suddenly in your church hanging out you
got to have meals to get you know maybe
they had something else to do this is
vocation for us it has to be vocation
for them we have to prayerfully discern
are they called by God to be in
partnership and are we called by God to
be in partnership there has to be room
for discernment not great knows where
come in all right discernment is the
first test next not just are they do
they discern that their own call is to
be in partnership but do they have an
inclination and desire to be in a real
relationship I've been on mission trips
where they were delighted to have his
come we had terrific worship we didn't
see the pass through the whole week
which is fine it's not his job to be our
host but maybe he wasn't as calling to
be our host right sometimes it is and
sometimes it's not we can look for
places where the host wants to be in
relationship where the whole community
wants to be relationship in biloxi last
year 25 churches all organized by that
hope CDA wanted a festival week where
the whole community could rise up and
declare hope over against the despair of
Hurricane Katrina so the whole community
made a gathering possible it gets even
better when it's the church the worst
let me say worse the least fruitful
worship is we're on a mission site at a
habitat place we live by ourselves we
work on a site we see no one during the
week and on Sunday morning we bomb down
to first baptist church of whatever and
we walk in as a surprise they do the
best they can to welcome
we do the best we can to be in
relationship with them that's it the
best is if the church wants to be in a
relationship before you start and after
you leave and all the time that you're
there and even better do these does the
youth group want to be in relationship
can we get a youth group to youth group
relationship going now we get that right
now we get that not only do we want to
have relationship on the trip what is
the possibility of enduring relationship
seven mission trips with the same
partners to Guatemala to tow out the
Puerto Rico to opelousas louisiana to
South Carolina to west region together
right that's when it gets rich when we
are partnering with them and going to a
third side and living together and
working together and in relationship I'm
going to pass over the rest of this
except for two criteria you know I don't
think our kids come into my church on
Sunday morning with very high hopes of
the worship we have I think a lovely
mainline Protestant congregational
worship form and let's just say I don't
see my youth group there in any
significant numbers on Sunday morning
but there are communities and traditions
they love the worship right and they
find it vibrant and exciting that's a
criterion right and then final thing I
want to add to this searching for the
right partner is you know this whole
country is populated by saints these
amazing amazing people who have nothing
no Ford Foundation grant no state grant
no big population in their church that's
going to give them money and they're
doing amazing work because they get up
every morning they praise God they pray
and they just go against all odds and
serve and then they do amazing things I
want my kids to see those Saints I want
my kids to rub up against those things I
want them to know those saints exist who
do not live in fancy houses who do not
have fancy cars or do not have fancy
funders who have no security but are
doing amazing thing in God's name
because it inspires all of us all right
so that would be the other criteria
right on there all right nurturing
relationship with this group once you
find them this is going to be different
for everybody because it's obviously a
budget issue but if if Puerto Rico's
$275 round-trip air
air and you can possibly figure out a
way to add another $275 to your mission
trip so you can go to a site visit to
visit that place and begin the
relationship before you show up
obviously amazing can you find another
$275 to bring their pastor up to your
church for the Sunday you Commission
your kids for the mission trip and
preach or talk to your kids and your
congregation amazing can you find
another 295 dots for one of their kids
to come up so that their youth group in
your youth group begin to have these
little tendrils of relationship I know
it's a budget challenge I'm just saying
it's a good if you got somebody in your
congregation I can write you a check for
$275 so you can do it you can see each
of these things here or just elements on
page 18 and 19 of laying down those
gossamer strands of relationship that
make the relationship authentic and
create the possibility of true love and
on enduring relationship breaking out
during the trip itself we structure the
whole week around building relationship
relationship you know Bruno Bettelheim
says nobody can do community by saying
on three commun right community happens
is a byproduct of some other shared
venture so what we want is we want the
shared venture to start when we get
there so a typical work week for
instance when we are in TOA out the
puerto rico is we are working in a
community again run by a saint it's a
tradition of squatters that a movement
that began in brazil and it has migrated
to other places in latin america folks
who are dispossessed just go on to
public land dig in and hold on fight off
the authorities build their little
shacks at some point the authorities
don't want the shacks to burn down they
want there to be codes they want their
be electricity and they win so that was
the community we were going to but you
don't just show up on Monday morning to
do the work let's have a community-wide
breaking of bread and cleanup day where
everybody works together they get
integrated into our work teams so you
have relationships breaking out around
the work teams worship at the end of the
day praise God together learn each
other's songs Sunday morning come back
and we're
shipped together for sabbath worship
again in teams Sunday afternoon
fellowship event their kids and your
kids bonded up on teams remember the way
this goes is if it's 30 of them and 30
of you that's intense engagement
politeness etc for 45 minutes then you
run out of stuff to say and you start
retreating back to your comfort zones
but if they're broken up so that they're
on your work teams so that they're
working together in relation together
breaking bread together they don't have
to have a commonality of what they had
before the trip because they have shared
experiences on the trip so we want
relational work going on all week long
on the work site we want to integrate
their contractors and their volunteers
and their kids into our work teams on
the work site if possible Wednesday
night worship together which the youth
run if you've teamed up with the youth
group they probably are better leading
worship than we are and our kids and
their kids lead the worship together
come back around to Friday what our
tradition is is it's not for us to come
and you tell us thank you it's for us to
come until you thank you so our kids are
servants of that community they have a
carnival for the children in the early
afternoon then they serve and cook and
ten tables to have a banquet for our
host community that night which segues
into final worship which you saw going
on there so that's the way we end on
friday night trying to build
relationship with our host community all
week long the next thing i want to talk
about is how we develop relationship on
work teams you know when when i run on
my first mission trip what i saw was the
kids would kind of bounce around during
the week they'd have fun social
relationships at night and then on
friday when they had their final worship
before going home there was this amazing
cathartic experience amazing cathartic
sharing and trusting and worshipping and
loving and hugging and if they had
worked together on a site let's say at
18 kids and they were six working at
site a and 6 at B & 6 it's seen those
six of course we're much more closely
related because of their shared
experience all right well why are we
waiting for Friday
night why don't we front-load the
sharing and teams to at least the
beginning of the week with nightly
Vespers why don't we front-load it so
the teams are vests purring together so
the teams are running their own
devotionals in the morning so the teams
are running their own prayers on their
worksite well wait a minute why start at
the beginning of the mission trip when
I'd identify the work teams in October
so that the team relationships in depth
over the relationship is running all
year long building to the mission trip
now forming teams is more art than
science but the way we do it we've done
it since we are only 25 folks we click
bust right we click bust mathletes and
athletes right Goths and hipsters that
we mix them all up seniors and freshmen
we mix them all up what we tell each
child is right us a team preference card
you may identify one or two close
friends you'll be on the team with them
so you don't feel like I'm walking off
into the unknown all right but beyond
that it's going to be mix and match and
then the youth ministers knowing how the
dynamics of these are likely to work
construct teams at the end of October
and we work with those teams all year
long when there's a breakout
conversation on a youth group meeting
they break out his team's when they are
going to have different roles in worship
they break out in teams when we're
having games and competitions they break
out and teams we start Vespers in
November and December and they start to
get used to the vesper and sharing
tradition we're laying down relationship
all year long by time they get to the
mission trip you can have instead of
what the typical trip for me used to be
you can have a spiritual highlight of
the Holy Spirit just blowing the doors
off a group vesper on Tuesday night
instead of that final catharsis on
Friday night so building teams senior
leadership of those teams nurturing
those teams all year long Liza Bagley
stood up at our 200 75th anniversary and
she was the child to speak to the
congregation for our anniversary worship
and she said I'm going off to college
next year I have no idea who I'm going
to meet I have no idea how many be
thrown into and then I'm going to go off
to work and through my whole life on me
thrown in one group after
thereafter enough and other folks I
don't even know who they are and I won't
know them when I meet them I know
something beautiful and wonderful is
going to happen because for four years I
have been in teams with people I started
not knowing at all and who I love dearly
whether had anything in common with them
or not I know God can do this wherever I
go that's the experience we want them to
have all right and that's the ethos
here's a here's a little a little
mission trip goal said I saw one of our
juniors heading off to a team meeting
and she had written her goals for the
mission trip I was never I was say what
more page 19 this was not something I
had ever done would you now still don't
do when I go off to clergy retreats but
she had written her goals and objectives
for the trip they were as follows don't
have expectations keep in mind that the
main goal is to let God serve through
you don't hang out only with your
friends if you see someone alone go sit
with them and have a substantial
conversation not just a time filler
never take the first shower never eat
until you were sure everyone else will
have enough food always look to light
and someone else's load don't only get
to know people on your team branch out
make sure you are combined with the
community it's about them not you make
the experience a religious experience
for you reflect on your experiences yeah
thank you lord thank you lord that's why
we do you three right that that kind of
grace can break out I want to flip ahead
to practices the part of pilgrimage read
you know I've given you about 30 pages
of experts of books on the theology in
the anthropology and the practices of
pilgrimages the essence of pilgrimage
was intentionality before you go leaving
your comfort zone being on the road and
in this liminal place neither here nor
there where it's a thin space right
walking with folks with whom you share
your lives as you walk and engaging in
practices all along the way of the faith
that leads you closer to God celebrating
your arrival and your engagement at the
destination
gratitude for the experience practices
on the way home memorialized and reflect
on what you have when you get back those
are the practices of our faith so we
want to have thoughtful devotionals in
the morning and we want to have
thoughtful Vespers in the evening we
want to have them led by our seniors
because that's where we have our senior
ownership and the migration of this has
been from random Vespers to greatest
hits Vespers to with Jonah Bartlett's up
whereas Jonah YTS grad Jonah Bartlett's
help Jonah said well why don't we make
the Vesper week intentional we'll have a
theme we're going to drive through the
week will cover the theme on nightly
shaped Vespers leaving room for the kids
to bring their own self disclosure and
sharing and we'll twin the evening
Vesper with the morning devotional right
woman who worked at our church great
great educator Ivy Beckwith perhaps
you've read her work Ivy Beckwith says
the way you shape understanding the way
you teach people to see the experience
of the Christian lens is prepare engage
reflect right when we had our first
mission trips and there was amazing
experience I'd say what happened kids
and they go what a high what a rush what
a buzz what were they shaped by drugs
drugs they had drug vocabulary right if
you don't want them to have drug
vocabulary for these experiences and you
want to decode them according to we
understand the spirit is doing you have
to prepare them to see what's going to
happen then they engage in the
experience then they reflect on it
afterwards that begins to shape their
understanding of what they've
experienced and the best way to do that
is set up the preparation to prepare in
the morning devotional and then do the
reflection at the end of the day with
the engagement in the middle I mean easy
example right Matthew 25 least of these
right you you do the judgment of the
nations as a devotional and you set up
the notion that where will you see
Christ in the least of these amongst you
they go looking during the day for
seeing Christ in their encounters and
they come back at the end of the day and
they reflect where did you see Christ
today right prepare engage reflect
the other thing I'd want to note is
worship is obviously important part of
this and that creates a little bit of
attention in in worship which is you
know my kids would rather have a worship
form that's very different from our
church worship form but if we're
training them and habituating them to
one form of worship that is completely
disconnected to our denominational
tradition we're just preparing them to
sail all right so are our integration is
the outside form will track the forms of
our worship but the style of the prayer
the style of the music their own
testimonies will shape in their own way
the worship experience that they have so
that's its kind of a summary of where we
are in worship shall we take a little
break do a little workshop all right
let's take five or ten minutes all right
beloved youth ministers
we have a very short but very important
section coven ental behavior you
remember I said that the three legs of
our youth ministry stool or
unconditional love and acceptance clear
and understandable boundaries and
Covenants participation in something
larger than yourself I'm sure it doesn't
take you more than a second to figure
out that all these are part of turning
away from self right each of these pulls
you away from a self-centered consumer
materialist life into community into
engagement with God into covenant into
something larger than yourself I used to
think I used to think that the progress
on the progress on building program was
when we were on the offense I hated when
bad behavior or disruptions or conflict
dragged us down and I hated all the
energy we had to put into having a safe
and appropriate youth group what I've
come to think is actually the metaphor
is more like field position in a
football game you want to go down the
field on offense but you do not want to
give up ground on defense both are
important and the defense element of
youth ministry is constructive by in
around coven ental behavior so you don't
get thrown for gigantic losses when the
kid goes off campus smokes dope you have
to gather everybody you have to do
debriefs you have to work it out you
have to have reconciliation and you
spend a day doing it right you'd rather
you not go there so coven ental behavior
is important it's going to do just one
out of sequence clip because this is
this is a little bit now let's just pass
on the clip we'll pass on the clip
covenant will behavior here's here's the
way we have come to go after this first
of all you know eric erickson said kids
are built to recoil against Authority
that's what they do in adolescents
they're individually they're built to
beat you they're built to escape the
rules right that's part a they're built
to ask a
and recoil against rules they don't
claim as their own if they claim them as
their own they're actually rather
Pharisaic about them right there
actually a little brittle the trick in
covenant or behavior the aspiration the
mission the yearning is for them to own
their own covenants of behavior all
right which requires that they be
reasonable not if you if you clamp them
down too much you will provoke force
recoil all right give them as much
freedom as you sensibly can keeping the
boundaries clear and safe bright lines
rather than blurred lines communicated
steadily so establish your ethos early
and reaffirm often Jack Welch that great
guru of youth ministry when he was
president of GE used to say it's not
enough to have a mission statement you
have to repeat it hundreds and hundreds
of times for the culture to buy in to
the vision we have a behavioral covenant
before they even sign up for the mission
trip they understand what it means they
have to sign each it's a covenant it's
not a contract it's a covenant the
parents have to sign the Covenant this
is who we are this is what we do this is
what we're about we're not shy about
having coven int'l boundaries we have a
10 commandments presentation before
every mission trip and you can find the
10 commandments in your notebooks but
here's the key the seniors deliver the
Ten Commandments right the seniors of
course work it into a skit and they work
at a skit for each of the commandments
which the aspiration is and what not to
do if the seniors own the Covenant if
the seniors are if the seniors own the
Covenant the kids will own the Covenant
all right and the seniors present it
because they own it the gift of a zero
tolerance policy right this is a little
counterintuitive right but we have a
zero tolerance for substances cigarettes
stealing sexual behavior I don't mean
appropriate section leave no sexual
behavior all right yo man that's going
to force a recall they're going to hate
that they're going to try to beat you to
it you know what
here's the little talk I give to them
before the trip and the seniors do the
rest of it but I say you have incredibly
difficult decisions to make every week
about substances tough tough communal
peer decisions we hope you make healthy
decisions and we're here to help you
make healthy decisions guess how easy
it's going to be for the next 10 days no
decisions you're free no decisions you
have really difficult decisions to make
about what is and what is not
appropriate sexual behavior with people
that you have affection or love for it's
tough to make those decisions I'm so
glad I'm not a kid today here's how easy
it's going to be for 10 days no
decisions you know I've gotten standing
ovations at the end of that talk and I
always get a robust set of applause what
a relief all this angst of being a
teenager navigating these questions I
don't have to for 10 days and then they
know we catch in the woodshed you're
going home right that's just the way it
goes and we have just done it twice in
20 years but you don't have to do it
more than that all right clear and
understandable and acceptable boundaries
the point of this is why make to them is
we're about to have more fun than
anybody should be allowed to have this
is going to be the most amazing
experience we're ever going to have we
have this experience even though there
are a hundred fifty of you and only a
handful of us you can beat us at any
time you want on any of these rules the
only reason we get to do this is your
parents trust that you won't you want to
do it again next year we got to be on
the same page we got to be on the same
page secret weapon senior leadership
senior when the seniors on these rules
it's the seniors trip they don't want
the trip messed up by all those meetings
and conversations and reconciliations
it's their trip favorite little story
were on a ski trip and a freshman who
ain't quite on the program is reaching
into his backpack and pulling out a
joint but he has the misfortune of being
next to a senior senior what are you the
biggest idiot in creation this is my
trip don't mess with my trip what do you
think you know how bad this trips going
to go give me that don't you ever think
of doing that again now much more
effective that is than me trying to
police that rule if the seniors own the
Covenant nobody else is going to mess
again all the senior has to do is go
dude that ain't cool done it's over let
the group own their own covenant of
behavior and we get different outcomes
behavior on host sites you know our kids
are used to traveling with mom and dad
on tourist trips etc and they're used to
being consumers they go into the hotel
room how do they leave it they go to the
beach how do they leave they got towels
at the pool how do they leave it nagging
and shouting at them to be respectful of
host property whether it's a restaurant
or omission center is a loser what we
want to convert is we want to convert
them into being servants of the host
your servants of this restaurant your
servants of this recreational facility
or servants of this mission center your
servants of this church and one of our
services is going to be we're going to
leave it better than we came that's who
we are that's our ethos all right that
converts the behavior on the site the
second thing we do with that behavior
conversion is it never really works to
say so we're all going to keep the
bathrooms clean and they're going to be
clean at the end the week when everybody
is responsible who's responsible nobody
so our teams have daily responsibilities
and the advisor has that delegated
distributed responsibility you're the
advisor of team a team a has the
bathrooms we don't move until adviser
checks in and says bathrooms clean they
own it they responsible they get it
advisors or your team advisors
responsible again does it work if you
just start this delegated responsibility
on the mission trip itself of course not
that's too big a culture change that
that culture of assigned responsibility
is something that you ingrain all year
long and then it's set and forget' on
the mission trip itself clear and
understandable boundaries kids on the
boundaries in the covenants themselves
seniors on the covenants so that they
help you get there we are servants of
those that we eat with that we worship
with where we stay etc and then finally
don't force recoil here the two keys on
that forcing recall to me and we have so
many great things to do on a mission
trip so many opportunities
relationship engagement work service etc
if you over schedule the kids they're
just coiled Springs needing to unwind we
have to have the discipline of letting
them have time just to be kids I don't
know about your community my kids are
over scheduled in their home lies by a
factor of 10 they don't ever get a
chance to be kids we very intentionally
on a mission trip leave to our blocks of
time hour and a half block of time just
be stand down we're not barking at you
you don't have to be anywhere you don't
to do anything you don't have to perform
anything just be kids being relationship
have fun basketball courts their
swimming pools their card games going on
over here board games going over their
guitars playing down there just just
stand down give them space so that you
don't quarrel the spring the other thing
that goes into this is you know you've
all taken some some good heart of the
adult volunteers with you on a trip and
you say I want everybody on the bus in
five minutes and the adult says what I
want everybody on the bus in five
minutes and then the other adult says I
want everyone in the bus in five minutes
and the kids are barked at non-stop
right bark bark bark bark bark bark bark
what happens then white noise white
noise so the two things we try to keep
in mind is try to figure out how
parsimonious you can be about
instruction I don't really need their
attention until that point I'm not going
to ask for it let it go until you really
need to talk to them only talk to them
one you really do need to talk to them
tell them what they need to know and
then don't tell him again all right and
don't let the adult volunteer the team
leader the visiting advisor don't let
everybody pile on with the authority
assertion we're just beating them into a
space where they're going to want to
recoil against the space or tune it out
and again with seniors of the way that
looks is all I expect carolina's joan
and have to do is go seniors and the
seniors go Shh and if you're standing
next when you're still talking the
senior goes Shh and we're done last
thing I'd say and I know these are
really nuts and bolts you points you
shouldn't raise your voice if
don't have to if you shout and then I
paying attention you've taught him
you'll shout louder and louder and
louder and louder and louder and they
know they are incredibly tuned they know
when the tone is finally got to the
point where they really have to pay
attention right don't we don't want to
train our kids in that there should be
mutual respect that you're not going to
say something unless you expect them to
listen and when you do they will so if I
said don't assert yourself any more than
you have to the next point we never
research yourself unless you're going to
get attention right I'm waiting you know
what's the ferris bueller you know so
don't ask for attention more than you
need and then make sure you get it when
you have it okay that's our coven int'l
behavior will take another break beloved
us ministers home stretch home stretch
ten minutes on engagement with parents
and home congregation when I was
beginning in ministry we started
congregation wide mission project after
school enrichment and the model that we
used was the most phenomenal charter
school I've ever seen started by a
fellow by name of a B Whitfield in East
New York a B woodfield brings passion he
brings energy former Dallas Cowboy cool
all right and it's a phenomenal school
in an incredibly poor neighborhood and
the kids achieve three grade levels
above new york city public schools etc
they all mostly get scholarships to move
on from there he has a rule every mom
must pay 50 bucks a month the moms don't
have 50 bucks a month how can you ask a
be 50 bucks a month from the moms how
can you do this he goes it gets me a
little self selection for moms who care
and are invested in our program somehow
I got 600 kids here where mom found 50
bucks mom cares about the homework mom
cares about what's going on because it's
tough all right now we don't have that
same community but the point is
your kids in high school are making a
lot of autonomous decisions about their
time because they often have course mom
still has a lot to say about is it youth
group or travel soccer is it youth group
or Olympic Development is it youth group
or s80 prep is a youth group or
all-state band is a youth group or
tutors is at youth group etc well mom's
not being a bad mom remember remember
Andy roots question why our moms like
this because they love their kids and in
this culture they have aspirations for
opportunities that would require a lot
of hard work so what is our answer it
can't be bad moms you're not doing the
right thing you should turn them loose
for youth group stop getting in the way
of our developmental formation
activities we've got to convert mom into
the value dad into the value of the
youth group if I was talking about
relationship for most of this talk it
means relationship with the parents to
relationship with the kids relationship
with the advisors relationship with the
seniors relationship with the host
Church relationship with the host youth
group relationship with a host community
relationship with your own parents and
relationship with your own congregation
so we don't charge the parents 50 bucks
just to have the kid in the program but
we require that they come to a parents
meeting at the beginning of the year oh
they don't have time for that and
they're not going to come and they miss
it they have to come the child does not
go on the mission trip of the parents
did not come to the parents meeting or
the makeup that we throw out there to
try to give them a chance and then we
use the parents meeting not really to
just push bureaucratic paper they can
all read this if they want to know how
the program works we use the parents
meeting to lift up the beauty and the
transformation and the value that's
coming into their child's life if
they'll support the time we start with a
little videotape where's Chris CUDA
there's Chris good he made all these
movies killer videographer thank you
Chris this is one of Chris's movies that
we do to try to drive the values
unconditional love and acceptance clear
and understandable boundaries
participation in something larger than
yourself for the parents
you
hold on to me as we go as we roll down
this unfamiliar role not on this way
string us along just know you're not
long cuz I'm gonna make this place your
No
so
so far
you know the old Liz Lemon line I want
some of that right parents look at the
video and read the pamphlet you the guy
and they go I get it I wish somewhere in
my child's life they had this and then
the fight over travel soccer the
festival of lacrosse in Northern
Virginia tittered sitter we start to win
those fights because the parents care
and understand the values the theology
the spirituality etc what else do we do
we have parents are required at that
meeting to volunteer in several roles
during the year to engage and helping
the youth group right engagement this is
our shared ministry it's that you know
one of the larger movements that you've
you've read Marco Ruiz works and chap
Clark's is kids are not farmed out to
youth ministers to learn the faith it's
primarily a parent's job right we're
partnering with the parents and you're
partnering with us by engaging as
volunteers we're moving towards parent
adopted teams probably not the team your
child's on but team parents so when you
have a team dinner a team breakout
there's modeling for our children of
adults in the church who are living
lives of faith with whom they're in
relationship and who care about them we
invite our parents tonight is youth
worship one of the things Carolina and
Jonah have done is they've not just
taken that we do youth worship once a
month but they've teed the high school
kids up that they're leading worship for
their younger brothers and sisters so if
you had high school worship and suddenly
had nine year olds coming in I think the
high school kids would recoil oh my gosh
you've got a bunch of little kids here
but if they're doing it for the kids
they're testifying they're witnessing
their preaching they're praying it's
cetera they've bought this as one of the
areas of service and then Caroline and
Jonah invite the parents to come to
these worship services as well and we
start to get relationship between the
parents and the youth ministry we have
an adult mission trip gets through
ninety-five percent of the people on the
adult mission trips are their parents
who go man my kid hey mom for the
mission trip I want to do one of those
and when they go on the mission trip
themselves of course they're in release
ship with the mission and values that
their kids are in relationship with all
right that's parents nurturing
relationship with the home church you
know you know they'll ken de Cressi Dean
critique that we are creating ghettos of
our kids and they are disconnected from
the church the church mrs. this as well
right the congregation that just farms
the kids out and doesn't have anything
to do with them doesn't feel engaged
with the youth group so we want a
pattern and a habit and a practice of
our kids engaging our home church so we
have yg gives back days we do a rake and
run we gather up any of the folks in the
church or having a hard time raking
their lawns the fall leaves and the
team's distribute out on a Saturday yg
kids are on their way to you it's not
just the Biloxi Mississippi it's to our
own seniors all right rake and run the
YG serves a pancake breakfast around
child church meetings and this year when
we were all without power around
hurricane sandy we had a fellowship
dinner where YG cooked a fellowship
dinner for all those folks nobody had
power everybody been eating hash out of
a can but they came to the church and
they got a spaghetti dinner served by
cooked by the youth group and they go we
get it this is youth group is not just
somebody were right checks to their part
of our community we do the commissioning
of the seniors in the meeting house in
worship right so you got 52 seniors and
the parents go congregation goes yeah
they're ours we're commissioning them
off as missionaries we commissioned the
entire youth group for their mission
trip in the meeting house at regular
worship and the congregation stands and
covenants to support them in their
mission etc we have at the end of the
trip where youth sunday you know here
the three big days in our church during
the year Christmas Easter and youth
sunday because when the kids come back
from the mission trip and run the
service play the music and testify and
five kids in a row stand up and say my
life has been changed by Jesus Christ
coming into my life I felt the spirit in
these ways what are the parents going I
want some of that right and so they are
engaged with the youth group that we we
we bust all the doors on you Sunday it
is the third-largest we have in a
significant number of adult members of
our church who say I joined the church
because I visited on youth
sunday and I said I want to be part of a
church like this alright so that's the
last point I want to make engagement
relationship not only with the parents
but also between our youth group and the
church itself with that we'll take one
more break and then we'll pray and go
all right one more break okay beloved
youth ministers seniors thank you for
coming thank you for what you do we are
in a world where we know the secret is
this is the most fun fulfilling a crazy
cool thing to do in ministry but the
rest of the world doesn't necessarily
affirm that right so sometimes it's
lonely and we're out there on our own I
hope what comes out of this group is
we're not lonely because we have each
other in the opportunity to come and
reflects so thank you for what you do
one product placement is Michael Burt
here today my real job was warm-up act
for Michael bird who is our next speaker
amazing cool program an Episcopal Church
in bronxville where michael has brought
you know deep roots of anglican
spirituality into helping the kids
develop a rule of life at the beginning
of the year they covenant they're
anointed and then they live it out
week-to-week Michael's going to share
spiritual formation and youth group and
one of the great youth ministers in the
country so that's next month right thank
you Michael yes yep think so we'll both
check our schedules well whenever
whenever it's going to be is going to be
he'll show up all right don't forget
youth ministry initiative fellows
whether the youth ministry initiative
fellows who are here stand and Rudy
Antonio Elliott Mon Kelsey Dallas Kendra
Joyner these are outstanding amazing
Yale students who are working with our
youth ministry they get whatever they
get paid as youth ministry team advisors
but the youth ministry initiative gives
them robust scholarships that go
straight to Yale and help carry the load
all right so that we can encourage folks
who want to try youth ministry to go and
do them they sit with me for an hour and
a half of theological reflection on what
they experienced during the week
hands-on plus reflection you should have
one of these at your church we would be
glad to pay for it so come back to me
about whether you'd like to have a
fellow assigned next
year and if it's multiple churches will
all gather up here for the theological
reflection so thank you Kelsey and
Kendra and Elliot if this asked them out
later if this isn't the coolest thing
they ever did and I hope they'll still
say yes all right let's uh let's say a
prayer gracious God we know all these
children were your children before they
are our children to care for we care for
them in your name and pray that we too
would be open as channels to your love
flowing through us into them that they
might experience the abundant life that
you intend for them that they might take
hold of the life that really is life
that they might know that they are loved
and come to love you in return blessed
to us into our ministries this week we
pray in Jesus name Amen thank you thanks